le calme avant l'appel aux urnes ce
dimanche 11 avril 25 millions de
péruviens sont appelés à choisir leur
nouveau président et renouveler le
congrès pour ce scrutin
les péruviens ont l'embarras du choix
pas moins de dix-huit candidats briguent
le poste
problème le favori ne figure pas sur la
liste des prétendants déclarés selon les
derniers sondages
c'est le vote blanc ou nul qui
l'emporterait avec près de 20 à 25% des
suffrages
pire selon ipsos perd où seuls trois
candidats dépasserait la barre des 10%
au premier tour lionil escanaux veronica
mendoça et hernando de soto
ce sera sans aucun doute l'élection la
plus ouverte de l'histoire du perron
des chiffres inquiétants qui résume le
faible engouement des péruviens pour
cette présidentielle
le pays est touché par de multiples
scandales de corruption qui ont
notamment a mené à la destitution des
deux derniers chefs d'état pedro pablo
cousine ski et martin vizcarra ce qui
entraîne un vrai ras-le-bol du côté des
politiciens
le père on veut être une puissance
mondiale nous en avons assez de la
corruption mais aussi des citoyens
j'espère qu'il y aura une opportunité
pour les jeunes et un grand changement
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de corruption
dans notre pays espérons qu'il n'y en
aura plus
quel exemple allons nous donner à nos
enfants c'est la raison pour laquelle le
pays ne se développe pas le pérou doit
également faire face à la crise du coc
vide
le pays est l'un des plus touché
d'amérique du sud avec 1.5 million de
cas positifs et plus de cinquante mille
décès quatre candidats à la
présidentielle ont également contracté
le virus ces dernières semaines malgré
la situation sanitaire
un sondage annonce que plus de 80 % des
électeurs se rendront aux urnes ce
dimanche
et pour cause au pérou le vote est
obligatoire